[Music]
subaru park the sponsor of this segment
is now the first major league stocker
stadium to have reached zero landfill
status it has placed more than 100
containers around the park where
visitors can separate their waste zero
landfill means that absolutely nothing
from subaru park goes into a landfill no
waste of any kind here's more
[Music]
zero landfill means that absolutely no
waste from the entire subaru park goes
to landfill what i mean by that is no
cup no bottle no hot dog no french fry
container and then that french fry can
actually go in compost
awesome thank you so much for helping us
in 2019 the recycling rate here at
subaru park was 11
today we're at over 90 percent so it's
such a huge difference hi there how are
you that's actually going to go in
compost
yep all this yep
so if you've put something on your curb
this morning for the trash man to pick
up you've sent more to a landfill than
the stadium has
first off i think it shows tremendous
leadership from subaru the vision that
they've had and the courage that they've
had to execute something like this is
incredible to be the first soccer
specific stadium in the mls that's zero
landfill and quite frankly when you look
across the world there's very few
stadiums that are zero landfill it's
fixed with their dna it fits with who
they are
it fits with their ideas of doing good
and doing positive things in the
community we have a long history with
building zero landfill manufacturing
facilities so subaru brought our
expertise
to the union and together we work to
create a new process and a new set of
steps
yeah look i think each one of us sits in
a leadership position to do something
good in the community to set a positive
example in the community
it shows that we mean
positive things in the community we want
to do positive things in the community
and hopefully our fans will get around
this as well well creating the first
zero landfill mls stadium is really a
big deal and i think it sets a great
example for all mls clubs in all mls
stadiums to say that we can do better to
help support the environment subaru and
the union found a way to create a zero
landfill mls soccer stadium and now
everybody else knows it can be done
thank you to subaru for sponsoring this
segment las vegas now we will